take that back I never said cuzz that's
too
far
[Music]
yeah think back to times you were
arguing with a partner either your
present one or a previous one what is
the worst thing you ever said to them oh
so stupid no jo did Dri go first you
guys are so dumb you guys are asshle no
you don't have to go first hey that was
a good setup though what the [__] was
that really the next topic you're lying
organic you just wrote that just now you
know so thing I said I did not right i'm
let me let me get a feel for the room
first to see how bad we're
going no don't use that one pick a
different one yeah don't use that one oh
obviously or use that one will bleep it
but keep zoom in on your mouth no I've
said worse things I've said way worse
things really what's
I said such bad things I don't even
remember can you repeat the question one
more time all right so In the Heat of an
argument with a partner present or past
what's the worst thing you ever said
you're trying to self-incriminate us I
mean if this is something that already
got fixed then I guess it's not too bad
unless you never really atoned for it
then yeah you're in trouble I broke up
with Nikki when she destroyed my coffee
table when did she destroy that again
why is that even a destroy she destroy
my coffee table how did she destroy it
last coffee table that I got from
Ashley's Furniture it was like the most
expensive thing I had ever bought at the
time Ashley's is pretty expensive thank
you I got a couch with the coffee table
like a little combination set and then I
probably spent $650 on the combo and
that was a lot for me at the time and
then um that progressed through my
previous relationship I took the couch
and the obviously cuz it's leather couch
[__] hate leather couches so I took
it with me for my single life okay so
now I have my my coffee table which by
the way goes so well with the couch you
can't find a coffee table that goes well
with the couch and then Nikki's giving
me hell one morning because um I didn't
wash dishes the way she wanted me to
whatever that's about right like I
washed a dish and I put it away and
she's like there's still splotches and
all [__] and I'm like don't [__] tell
me what to do [__] don't [__] tell
me how to do it I do it my way don't try
to tell me how to do your way and then
she like we got an argument about bring
her teeth cuz I brush my teeth twice a
day and she brushes her teeth once a day
and like she's just trying to tell me
like she threw away my toothbrush
because I she like was like it was old
it was all flattened the bristles were
all [__] and I was like I how about I
need a toothbrush [__] cuz I I brush my
teeth at night and she doesn't brush her
teeth at night and I'm like I need my
[__] toothbrush so I got to go buy a
toothbrush so [__] you and all that [__]
and then so and then
basic I dumped Nikki I was like I'm so
sick of this [__] like this was the
first year of our relationship I was
like I'm so sick of this [__] like I
it's constant with you constant with you
[__] Conant War I'm at War I wake up
I got to put [__] war paint on I
don't want to be in a relationship I
don't want to be at War and then I was
like we're done I'm I'm done with this
[__] and then she's like oh we're done
oh we're [__] done and then she grabs
my coffee table and she flips it like a
[__] football oh [__] and it hit my
50 weight that I have cuz I can curl 50
like it's
nothing that's a lot still can by the
way let's go
baby I told you he's buffed dude like
it's nothing I told you nothing paper
weight no so then
um coffee table hit my weight uhhuh the
glass part hit it it shattered oh and
then I was like you're [__] crazy
just like your [__] mother I didn't say
that
no but I was like I was like you're
[__] crazy what the [__] and all [__]
yeah and then and then she goes into the
bathroom of our like we had like a an
apartment and she goes into the bathroom
and then I like went to the door to like
go [__] downstairs and go in the car
and like be a Sabby little [__] and
stuff but then I was like just something
stopped me I swear to God something
stopped me it was like the force of the
[__] Universe stopped me I was like
you will regret this forever and I was
like what the [__] and I and I was like
I was so mad but then I was so like
weirdly at peace huh and like calm and
like I just had all my thoughts back and
like it was like it was like I got to go
back in time and like I was myself again
I was like oh I'm about to [__] this up
I'm about to [__] up like one of the
best things that I've I've ever
encountered cuz me and Nikki went hot
and heavy I me and my chick got broke up
previous to Nikki I was with Nikki N9
Days Later full
penetration to completion and I'm
telling you man we were hot and heavy
but we were like fiery and like but like
I I knew I loved her from the minute we
got together and I told my buddy Mike
Gallagher that and then like he was like
you're crazy dude this is a hookup come
on but like it just it there something
about Nikki just like it all locked in
and then during this moment I was like
I'm about to throw it all away so then I
I I promised myself I was like if I go
in there right now if I go to the
bathroom and I say hey we're good I'm
like I want to be back with you I'm
sorry that I could never do this to her
again I could never make her feel
insecure about a relationship again
where she knows that if we get into an
argument I'm going to use the breakup
button right which me and Nikki have on
our podcast [__] they don't tell you we
have a break up button it's like you
should break up but like that's only in
use underglass in extreme cases right
not like just [__] willy-nilly
casually yeah cuz you're you're
degrading your relationship if you you
feel like you can't work [__] out so
then I went back in the bathroom I was
like I'm so [__] sorry I did not mean
what I said I apologize to the eenth
degree
and then honestly from then on we had a
the Gucci time we we we've had fights
but our conflict resolution is the is
the thing I brag about not we don't
fight but when we do we can fix it fast
and I think that that's like the beauty
is I I understand her more now and I've
understood her way more obviously that
was like [__] you know 10 years but I
didn't know I didn't know I was the
person who said I think you're autistic
but that was like probably three years
in but still like I figured out I've
just been figuring her out the whole
time and it's a beautiful thing to to
learn about your partner if you really
love somebody learning more about them
is maybe the most fun thing you can do
so yeah I really that was definitely the
worst thing I said and I'm so glad we
went through it you called her crazy
[__] crazy [__] [__] I said I
hate your [__] mother oh no I didn't
say that I wish I did I can't tell which
things you actually said go back in time
and say it did you say that like at one
point like you were like this you're
like your mom or you said something like
that and you said you never said that I
said you're like your [__] [__] mother
but I didn't actually say that oh I
actually actually said that there's mine
what I didn't say [__] cuz she's not a
[__] or [__] I just used other is it
adjectives yeah yeah what other
adjectives like [__] no creative ones
that she's not really but you can use
your imagination just think of the worst
ones
loose oh that's good I don't know if her
mom's loose she whistles while she walks
Noy you're going pretty good damn it
what was the situation it was I don't
want to talk about it it was wrong slaus
you know like when you could like you
know like when you bring up like uh like
gay childhood trauma or stuff like that
you go that far like stuff like that and
bring back yeah sometimes you become a
gang member like use like therapy to
degrade him oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
not going I'm not going to talk I'm not
going to talk about what I said but it
was pretty creative I even blew myself
like like a wannabe pedophile no whoa
wannabe I don't know pile give I can do
a different one I might have called uh
which is ironic uh might have said fat
[__] even though I was the one that was
fat like and it was like kind of weird
cuz I was like wait you're H fit like
hold on God damn I got this wrong you
know was going to you trying to hurt her
feelings yeah I was I was just basically
talking about myself yeah talking some
[__] all right it happens yeah that's it
what do you guys got so no no no we're
really focused on you now yeah you got
anything else my imagination I don't
know my imagination name is magn well
I'm going to have to say something
during this episode but I said it what
do you say Ryan what do you got M mine's
uh more funny now I think if you think
about it so you know the show Glee yeah
that's a show I would have loved but I
ended up hating it because my ex hooked
up with one of the dudes on
it [__] that show the funny the funny
thing there's a guy named Cory Monte he
he killed himself he's died I about to
ask is it one of be a live cast member
no he he died he died yeah half of that
cast is really one of my exes used to
always like talk about how she used to
date him and she'd be like yeah we dated
for a little bit we dated she would
always bring it up and then she told me
the story of how they like dated and it
was so clearly like a like he just
basically hooked up with her and never
call her again but I think to cope with
it she just calls it like oh we dated
for a period we were talking you know
like girls do that they try to like make
they don't want to be the mistress well
they don't want to just be devalued in
the scenario oh yeah same thing as dudes
that like get friends Zone but they said
they dated yeah you hear you're like oh
you're just friend zone it's to like the
degree where her like family watches cuz
they think that they used to date oh
dude what really was a throw away one IE
stand and then around the like I want to
say like maybe like fifth time she like
said it in conversation randomly cuz
like she'll watch Glee and I'll just be
like [__] and then like uh one time I
think we were at like a a bar or
something and she started talking about
it and I was like oh are you talking
about how you and Cory Monte used to
date and she's like yeah and I went well
you [__] him and he [__] you you
guys didn't [__] [__] date Okay and
like she just like could not deal with
hearing that and she just started World
Star she started crying cover protecting
Joe's ears protect him at all cost and I
was like he [__] [__] you okay you
didn't
date we're brothers that's a man who's
had enough dude good for you because
like as why is you bringing it up so
much when you already dating her I think
she's in the wrong here because like it
was a point of Pride for her because she
was like an actress toy and me when
wey she was kind of bringing it up as
like a oh you know like this is my
eligibility in this town a little bit
like I only date up and [__] and I was
like that sounds like CL chasing like I
don't need to shame like it was wrong
for me to like shame her and make her
but it must have been annoying for the
thousandth times it is but you guys are
dating and she's like I suck the [__]
out of that guy's talk and you're just
like well no seriously you got to put me
through this godd dang torture if she
had said stuff like that it would have
probably been more like funny to talk
about it but her denial of like we were
like dating was weirder to me and I'm
like yeah for sure prot just say you met
him in a bar and you had a one night
stand just say that like or stop sharing
it while you're [__] with your dude
why are you doing that it's so strange
it's like when you're like yeah it's
like you're like the victim but really
you're trying to like hyp a little bit
right oh my God I can't believe I did
that but it it happened with mean SE dog
you think it started like giving [__]
you know like me and coo like you start
giving them nicknames nicknames
distinctly remember like doing this [__]
like I like well yeah he [__] you
okay I was so like what did hey what did
she say previous to that what was her
quote is she like when I was when I was
taking Cory's M
teeth like what sent you over the edge I
don't I don't think it was anything
specific I think she just relates things
to that she bring it up whenever she can
yeah like she makes these memories that
never were real it's like dude he just
like and they escalate huh yeah and it's
just like as the as the current dude
you're just so like annoyed generally of
hearing about past guys let alone a dude
that's like on Glee and like and Glee
was like popping at the time he had a
two octave range it was pretty
good yeah so when he died he was dope
all right who's
next let's
go I'm just kidding Attitude Era
attitude ER we don't care yeah we don't
care we don't care anymore no no no that
was so much later anyway it didn't even
matter you had to a little bit happy I
wasn't happy cuz he didn't even know I
existed it' be different if he had sex
with her while I was with her but like
that was like a whole chapter can I just
add to this there's a thing in this town
cuz I'm in LA right now dude when I
moved to Korea Town right my first
apartment this chick same [__] I move in
me and my buddy Horton were living at
this little little pad right with my ex
at the time you had a friend named
Horton yeah his name is we all call him
Horton everyone you guys know him kind
of yeah okay so so he um so we're in the
apartment and me and Horton met this
chick who's like oh hey yeah I'm an
actress and she's like yeah I'm kind of
dating Jeremy Piven and it was like that
it was like that kind of [__] and I was
like like one of the first things she
said to us Jeremy PIV I'm like I'm like
we live in like the shittiest apartment
in Korea Town you're date Jeremy pivot
like you can't just like go hang out at
his place you're like hang out at your
place like carrying groceries up to your
[__] apartment with Jeremy Piven I
guess he lives here no so what happened
was we me and Horton looked her up on
IMDb
and like dude nobody she's been in
nothing like nothing like bro like not
even barely extras nothing and nothing
right okay so so in Her IMDb trivia
section shut up wres has been
romantically linked to Jeremy Piven oh
my God so she just [__] Jeremy Piven
and she's trying to like ride this like
storm of like news or whatever that
means she signed up for IMDb Pro just to
write right about herself and like he
was on Entourage at the time so it's
like
2006 2007 God yeah like sh but that was
like that's like the thing it's like a
thing you do like oh I'm I [__] this
guy like one night and like now he's
maybe my boyfriend and I'm star F it's a
thing wa dude that's that's another
level though on your [__] public
profile dude like and there's like maybe
a hundred hits on the profile there's
nothing except for her and and me and
Horton me and Horton fu
that's pretty bad but no you get you get
the sentiment of like when people say
that but I was wrong for I didn't need
to do all that [__] but like but it
would must have been she need to hear it
bro honestly I think some people need to
hear the truth will set you free it was
just like I broke her with that one
though dude really what she what was her
reaction I think she was so sold on the
fact that I believed it and I was like
oh that's so cool but did she continue
though so cool that you were [__] him
I know no she never I mean we [__]
broke up like really shortly after that
but like I just can't can't like the
next day I didn't need to I just didn't
need to do it like I could have just
broken up with I didn't need to like no
that was your purpose you have
to you needed to do that well there's
always got to be that like you
know moment you know where the [__]
the last drop in the bucket just tips
everything over and you're a patient guy
you probably let it go on for two years
before you said something I mean I
wasn't patient back then and we were
together like maybe like eight 8 months
by that point 8 months is a long time
for that she probably said it over a
thousand times I heard it a lot in the
beginning and then and then thought it
was done and then popped up at the end I
was
like you think she's with her guy now
and she's like yeah so me and Ry dog we
used to raw
dog you know from JK news we were going
to get married yeah yeah she say y that
again she could say that she's cool now
actually you know the guys that got
tattoos together the cool guys the
careful boy you know the careful boys
they're not dumb at all they're not the
dumbest guys all I mean one of them
is
you go to where IM DB page and [__]
Ryan INE from JK news [__] Ryan in
May has been romantically linked to Ryan
and may romantically by was romantically
scolded at public Bar imagine a one
night sand you say romantically linked
holy [__] [__] good for you yeah
that's rough what was yours Anthony uh
what was just B what do you mean REI guy
you come on REI guy you like REI work
hey you said something clever and [__]
up right to a girl come on you've never
like you probably made it to a punch you
never lost your [__] and like kind of
went off on some monologue did you mean
dance toward her not like that she
started crumping dude this is how I feel
what's the mean meanest thing you've
said cuz I also feel like you're pretty
levelheaded when it comes to like
emotions I don't think I've ever like
gone off the Rockers and said something
like [__] you never snapped but but I
have said things that I've like made you
know there's definitely one time where
uh like for example one of my
ex-girlfriends I think this like really
hurt her but it's not like overly mean
but just a moment where I looked at her
at the end of our relationship and I was
like look I really like you but I just
don't think I could ever love you and
that just like broke her and then we
ended our relationship after like
mild y' mild what you mean y' child play
dude y like I I don't know if I ever
said anything so like damn that was
[__] up I like Joe's just r Joe's just
like Jo Joe's found his [__] Nails
right now what's this [__] salsa
birie
[__] fck did you say Joe you've
never like had that moment where you you
like spat something out and you're like
oh [__] I wish I could
just never you've always said the right
thing no no I definitely didn't say the
right thing but I just said salsa bir
[__] you know what I mean there was a
time definitely where like Nina would
complain about her mom and the way that
her mom asked about [__] you know when
you like family like you complain about
family in a way that's like only family
does that oh yeah you breach that like
yeah one time she was like saying some
[__] and I was like you're just like
your [__] mom dude you can't complain
about that and she definitely got really
sad about that a this is dude Joe right
now by the way Joe right now is like
Hulk Hogan watching little kids wrestle
each other and he's just like all right
brother what goad
Joe hul context all right context
context was like you look like my
boyfriend I didn't know there was
something called verbal
abuse so this is a big
start officer I didn't know about the
law all I thought the type of abuse that
exists out there all I thought was if
you're not beating somebody up it's not
abuse yeah I do know there's like
psychological bullying and abuse I know
about that right so I go all right so
how can I dance my aggression around but
do it like safely okay yeah you do it
through words you know what I mean how
do you force someone to break themselves
but but the but the thing is
okay okay I want to tell you in stages
all right I want to say in high school
it was so bad cuz the relationships
you're in and and mind you I was in a
[__] stupid street gang and the type
of people I'm around and the type of
relationships I'm around everyone's
calling each other nword in a cool way
you know what I mean even when you love
each other you call each other that
right everyone so when you argue men and
women AR
and you'll hear every single
[__] [__] [__] punk [__]
[__] dumb ass [__] every single
word you could think of we would when we
fought we would call each other that ah
okay right and chicks said that N word
too the chicks would fight like man some
chicks will [__] be so wild as to hit
you in front of all your friends oh God
and come to your car and bring a zipple
lighter and try to burn your [__]
roof or the the fuzzy part at the top
the headliner right so yeah so coming
from that world right you think like oh
that is the worst it's going to get uh
so then like fast forward to like me
being a more mature guy and I'm like I
ain't going to say nothing wor that bad
just going to call you a little punk ass
[__] [__] [__] and that's mild and
you think that's taking it easy cuz I'm
thinking at taking it easy ass [__] ass
[__] is uh well you know what I never I
actually take that B I never said [__]
punk ass [__] that's too far punk ass
[__] is M punk ass [__] [__] ass
[__] [__] yeah [__] you just in case
you didn't hear [__] the first time
stupid ass [__] [__] [__]
all that [__]
[Laughter]
right all right we're hitting hot we're
hitting hot and then you know I was I
was is ready to share again
after okay that we I can share my story
I was like I was taught that's verbal
abuse who told who taught you that I
forgot I forgot that's probably my last
ex I don't know when you were getting
yelled at yeah I was like that's
verbal I was like what's that mean and
goes yeah you're abusing people through
your words and [__] and I'm like you
shouldn't you shouldn't use certain
words and I was like you know what that
makes a lot of sense here okay I think
from this point on I got to try to
control the mouth yeah so one less [__]
[__] punk ass [__] [__]
[__] oh yeah and it just rolls
off the the words very clearly when
you're angry very much so and then
um dude Joe's the mother I love how
we're all just telling our stories and
Joe meanwhile is the [__] Terminator
just sitting here like on standby
mode I'm not I'm not proud of it but
looking back sound proud of it no no I'm
just like wow how [__] stupid was I
that I thought that was normal that was
sparing the person but you know I would
say
until JK the type of people I were
around they normalized that not making
it okay but everyone's that guys and
girls would erupt right in front of you
at a party they'll [__] start
throwing fists and calling each other
the craziest [__] and you're pulling
them apart and then the guy is like
I'mma go in there pistol whip this [__]
and this and that and then like it gets
wild right like I saw one time a guy
girl started [__] arguing he [__]
gets a beer bottle and starts chucking
at at her and it's splashing falling
glasses going all over the place guys
are trying to cover her and then he's
getting mad that guys are trying to
protect and cover her and I'm just like
cucks are yeah like he's like yo no the
glass should hit her cuz she's a [__]
and then I'm just like this is [__]
wild this is crazy right so coming from
that kind of space where people are
abusive constantly toward each other
then I'm like okay then people in JK are
having normal relationships normal right
and then so like yeah yeah you
heightened your emotional intelligence
being
here hey man thanks thanks to you Steve
you don't you don't beat the [__] out of
Nikki so I I go you know what be more
like
Steve take tips from Steve be more like
Steve when he gets mad he doesn't throw
beer bottles he cheers
them I do step on our head a lot though
while we're [__] only while we're
[__] yeah yeah it gets hot in dude
the [__] quote of when the guys are
trying to protect the girl and he says
no the glass should hit her cuz she's a
[__]
[Laughter]
that's so harsh it's wild man Tyler do
you have any from any fights you've had
with a partner um not necessarily fight
one time I was like I didn't like you I
used to tell girls that I dated all the
time that I really like them oh hey
that's bad that's a Zinger that's [__]
up singer yeah I lied to girls a lot
what made you what were the
circumstances at where you felt like you
should say something like that I was
just going through the motions you know
what I saw on TV and stuff wow just
trying to like you know AE to all their
a lot I would date them for like you
know 6 months and then not have of
feeling for them so I'd be like so zero
attra zero attraction whatsoever um yeah
so the girls didn't have a gate on like
top girls like n91 pretty much tens and
tens and 10.5 10 taking them to the curb
dude taking them off the market just to
diss them later you know what's funny
she's all like guys are jerks little
does she know that he's
gay I'm not a guy
yeah yeah nothing like malicious though
like but that at the same time I would
say what I did was probably as malicious
as it gets yeah but I think that I think
that's still what do you think it was
for like it was just fun or you just
curious or like um I was just trying to
fit in socially you know you didn't come
to terms with like your sexuality at the
time or like what was it oh I like knew
but like I couldn't tell anybody cuz I
was in Missouri oh and because of like
situation and the religion and
everything yeah I came from a very
religious family I see so yeah we were
just trying out what Society expects out
of you yeah and then hot girls just ask
me out all the time so I was like yeah
sure why not so you were just tarnishing
all the tens in
Missouri you know they're still hot
let's go
baby sounds like a good is a Missouri 10
like a la6 la6 la6 five he said he said
I would say what he say I'm sorry he
said what he say our Missouri 10 in La 5
come he said I like a 6.5 uh Miami 4
five oh okay okay okay I don't know
there's lots of really hot girls and
guys Mis not going to lie I mean yeah if
you're raised in Missouri and like your
parents were drinking while you were PR
while they were pregnant with you what
city has the hottest people in Missouri
hottest what's like the hottest city I
feel like Kansas City actually has a lot
Kansas cityas C pretty pretty hot spot
they're playing right now do they I the
good thing about Missouri is like kind
of healthier for no no
uh the youth is healthier how fast you
took that everyone gets fat as they get
older in Missouri Nick likes the youth
huh what what' you say Nick what's the
worst thing you ever said uh I usually
this is going to sound so lame after you
guys a story it always does mine was
lame it always does but everybody knows
and they're looking forward to yours so
go ahead online or offline I've never
really called me and Tiff we we made a
rule like if we get arguments we don't
do any name calling that's what I should
have
done establish that so you guys were
mature so like in high school what what
what how to get to that though like
there's no exes that you Ed the waters
with yeah how what would make you make a
rule like that just SE how my parents
would [__] argue with each other and
I was like nah bro I'm not doing any of
that so it would be like but sometimes
when a word comes out of your mouth it
feels [__] good like I've never said
some [__] she she she's called me a
[__] like she's called me an idiot
like you know like nothing but what did
you respond with I just don't say
anything cuz I know if I [__] engage
it's going to be a problem did you call
you idiot yesterday for your
tattoo the the latest thing that she got
mad at me about and I was like having
conversation I was telling her how she
has attitude and she's like I don't have
attitude like no you have [__]
attitude bro like get the [__] out of
here but that's about it nothing crazy
like i' I've never anytime we had like a
a heated conversation it's like I'll
just stay silent or something and just
try to like remove myself from situ your
heated conversations you stay silent wow
he's a good little Cy Sal ver he's a
good little Cy boy [__] I just take
the insults and I just sit there I go
okay I need the difference is I know he
could kill so that's why I'm like Joe
shut the [__] up [__] ass [__]
[__] ass
[__] verbal
abuse that's Jo's love language verbal
abuse